[Music]  my name is alaphia  my story is true  i am a solitary creature by nature  i have no children or siblings nor  parents  i did want to have a husband  [Music]  if there is fate who can say  but in the grand bazaar of istanbul  i chose a memento  i like it whatever it is i'm sure it has  an interesting story  [Music]  so what will you wish for what is your  heart's desire  [Music]  i do have a question  what does one do with three wishes  you'll see  [Music]  oh  [Music]  there's no story about wishing that is  not a cautionary tale  we all have desires even if they remain  hidden from us  but it is your story and  i cannot wait to see where it goes  oh how it might end  hello hello  he'll be staying for a while  [Music]  i'm beginning to wish we've never met  make a wish  save yourself  i have a wish  [Music]  [Music]  you